you know motion I have a special
together that's out I know and that's
why would you see it no but I've been
it's you're such a fan of both of ours I
know it's so funny that you say
something like that because I don't have
a Netflix on my iPad and also on top of
it it's like he has Netflix on his I
have netflix on my by the way i 100% do
not expect you to watch my stand-ups no
but I'll tell you the reason why was why
don't you have one that's the reason why
all the questions that's the reason why
is because I'm such a lazy writer and I
hate my material and what yeah on and on
and on that is just one of those little
things that plagues me why don't you
retire it on a special yeah and then
you'd have to start over yeah but when I
asked about it they go well you want to
do a 15-minute one all the stand-ups
right that one I'm like what okay
they're doing these 15-minute Long's 15
minutes eight comics like a commis like
of you guys you never heard of oh and
please write more do you think the only
one I have heard of well motion I just
did like 30 minutes each which I thought
was plenty yeah but that was beats being
advertised a lot even on their platform
yeah it's the front if you go on yeah
the honeymoon is special if you go on
Instagram they I think they've added to
advertise or other people have and I see
it a lot but what does that have to do
with doing a 15-minute one because you
should have your own here's the thing
though Natasha Leggero you got to change
your last name no keep it thank you I
love it but here's the thing is is that
I've been doing it for so long and I'm
about to get I'm gonna bout to like just
vent a little bit here I'm gonna vent a
little bit okay is your past at the
comedy star correct of course yeah you
are you're a headliner well that's where
we met too because I we would go there
every Sunday like I'd say 15 years ago
we were there every Sunday not you you
already passed yeah but I would host
open mic sometimes I would come every
Sunday wait for Mitzi and she never came
and finally one day after three months
of every single Sunday she came did she
pass you she did but it would like took
another
it was like a different way that she
passed me it wasn't from going I think
she came in and was just like no one's
past something like yeah I remember one
time sitting next to her and I'm just
talking to her and they bring a comic I
don't hear cuz I'm talkin and Mitzi and
then all of a sudden a minute in she
goes she's just yelled up he doesn't
look up onstage it's louis c.k now i go
because he had an HBO special at the
time of his first one right so I turn
over I have a gun too and if I had it
I'd kill myself and he he wasn't even
did he did one minute and he laughed
that's how [ __ ] toward the end she
just didn't have her finger on the pulse
I don't think I definitely think she had
her finger on the pulse but I do think
she like had a funny wisdom to her she
did all those things I said all those
little things those are all from her
from her oh really
like she used to say you know hang out
there yeah Wow I used to go to when I
lived in San Diego she used to drive
down with Freddy Soto and this is when
Freddy so don't over very good friends
because hey dude we're going to bully
has come which at steak house which is
right around I don't think it's there
anymore and I used to eat steak with
Mitzi that's back and then and I was
already past so it was kind of cool but
um yeah what kind of things did she tell
you just the stuff that I've told you
you know meaning about like you know
bombing and all that I mean you know
tidbits you get from it is a sin to
support mediocrity is her big one you
know because but then she's like you
should be called Johnny Bananas right
Jackie Quinn should wear yellow soon
gianni bini Jackie banana or whatever
yeah yeah it was a guy named Jackie
Graham Jackie Graham yeah yeah Jackie
banana but I'm just saying the
mediocrity thing is like right but maybe
it's whatever her vert her vision is
your name
John campy - John kappa yolo do you
remember that yeah yeah here to put his
name on the list as John campy for like
5 years she named Carlos Mencia oh wow
what was his name that wholeness Wow
yeah he's half German people don't know
that Wow
that's why he's from Honduras if she
wanted him to like exploit that she was
smart in that way Brandon Jackson Purdue
he said you gotta wear a purple
turtleneck on stage so this poor [ __ ]
guy during the summer yeah and he's like
sweaty like sweats just what yeah yeah
she like you know what and you know back
in the 80s shoes I have one Russian
right yaha
right I have a gay guy like she wanted
the quota in many ways she's not wrong
to do that
I think Adam you know the new guy he
still does it he's like I need Sherrod
he says one night said Sherri Shepherd
has to come tonight like a wipe because
you know she's the only black girl on
black person on the lineup which is I'm
glad he is thinking in that way if it
was like 15 white dudes I think it's a
really yes it's very good to be
conscious of that yeah I think that
everyone's starting to like wake up to
that
but Mitzi did it in the eighties like
when I audition from one out me and she
saw me and she passed me she's like I'm
finally like an American Asian guy who
doesn't resort you know that kind of
thing he is you're like your own thing
you know cuz before the gooks that they
used to have
we're like ching chong e gooks like you
know yeah they look like you yes thank
you she used to eat at the steak house
with her that sounds fun she's in a tip
so we'd have to throw money
she just doesn't tip doesn't believe in
it shouldn't know why I don't know she
goes to a nice restaurant and doesn't
tip even 15%
we used to throw money on the table
that's all I know
Wow I'm glad your voice for that well I
know she also passed away so I feel a
little guilty for saying that oh that's
why you're lying yeah yeah yeah so if I
say it like flaga stuff yeah i'm have
staffing it yeah maybe pali one here
right you know but when i was out going
to say though is is that back to my
original point was that these negative
Netflix specials and whatnot is is that
being a regular playing that room and
being a regular it's not easy to do I
feel like you know when you're playing
the rooms and in in the three rooms
improv you know Comedy Store laugh act
especially the Comedy Store on you have
to be vetted they don't throw just
anyone up on stage they have to be you
know seen over the even sometimes years
and I feel like the industry they don't
look they just look at the whole thing
and I'm sure there are great comics that
do the what's that nerd place that they
do it noticed you know I mean or they do
you know there's a no meltdown that's
what I'm saying you know there's some
great you know coffee shop comics
probably you know but what well they
would probably rise to this no but today
they use coffee shop comics in these
things what things like get they get
things ahead of me in terms of life
here's what's happening it's becoming
easier to make it oh you know they mean
like think so of course cuz how many
comedians you know who've been at it for
four years and they have their own show
you're right it took people it took like
us like like 10 years at least yeah now
it's like it just doesn't take ten years
anymore so much yeah there's so many
networks that's also the same thing with
music it's like it's really hard to be a
massive Universal star now cuz there's
just so many ways to make it there's so
many just like you set up your niche
audience SAS is a very popular podcast
right yeah and it's very specific
you go on the road and they come see you
yeah yeah it's amazing yeah and they're
gonna love you I'll tell you that right
now part I don't know how I thought if
they love
Yonsei I don't know how I feel about
that like I in one way I encourage it
like when I when we do we collaborate
with a lot of like YouTube people and
stuff like that I love them I think
they're great we've had you to people on
the show right young people that have
been catapulted have you heard of this
guy Cameron Dallas no he's a youtuber
and he went on a national world tour of
a meet-and-greet because they don't have
a skill mediums pictures I mean
obviously it's very young girls yeah
yeah but yeah a lot of money Kant
doesn't sing doesn't do stand-up but
what does he do on YouTube that is just
like well faizon like weird like I guess
videos at skateboarding videos I don't
really know I don't spend a lot of time
on a CA called me and said hey there's
this company they wanted anyone needed
help from you and I said this is five
years ago I go alright what is it
they're like did they just have a bunch
of they signed a bunch of vine stars and
I go okay and they just want to have a
meeting with you there's some good money
in it for you I went I didn't know what
it was about I was showed up at this
company yeah and they had a catalog
people they're all millions of hit I
don't know I didn't do vine so I don't
know yeah hey we we want you to teach
our guys how did you stand up teach a
vine yeah because you know we want to be
able to generate income for them and we
think that live personal appearances
would be you know fruitful for and I go
yeah it's not something that you can
just teach like that it takes 10 15
years by yeah agent should have like
that abetted that yep I wouldn't [ __ ]
believe it
that's crazy crazy they just go to this
do you think he sells out stadiums of
people wanting a picture it's a lot of
people I think he does like skits from
what I've seen oh boy yeah I'll do
although I'll go on the road I was at
Schaumburg improv one show was like
my shows was like half-full
[Music]